[Music]
most of us use dollar bills every single
day but have you ever looked at the
paper closely did you know you can see
exactly where the money's been printed
and other secret symbols it holds you
won't believe the connection between the
US dollar and September 11 if you're new
here make sure you subscribe to our
channel and give this video a thumbs up
now let's explore the 10 mind-blowing
hidden secrets in the US dollar the
number 13 if you've studied the layout
and elements of the dollar bill you've
probably noticed there's a consistency
with the number 13 that can be seen on
feathers stars stripes and more it's a
tribute to original colonies and a
symbolic element that's featured more
than just once the number thirteen
represents the thirteen original
colonies of the United States which for
Delaware Pennsylvania New Jersey Georgia
Connecticut Massachusetts Bay Maryland
South Carolina New Hampshire Virginia
New York North Carolina Rhode Island and
Providence Plantations check the back of
the bill where you can see the two
circles together they comprised the
Great Seal of the United States an
element that took four years to get it
approved pay attention to the images in
the circles you can see the american
eagle holding 13 arrows of war in its
left talent the number 13 can also be
found on the shield which has 13 red and
white vertical stripes these stripes are
connected to the horizontal blue band
which represents the Congress uniting
the original colonies but that's not the
end of it have you ever counted the rows
on the pyramid it comes with 13 rows
that symbolize strength and duration of
the 13 original colonies we'll talk more
about the pyramid in just a bit because
it comes with phrases and messages you
probably never even noticed hey guys we
are so excited to announce we're
producing
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup hacks and so much more we are
sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section if you let
me hear from you see you there Latin
phrase on the Eagle the US dollar comes
with plenty of latin phrases that hold
meaningful messages you probably never
knew before unless you studied Latin or
did your own research
how many phrases have you noticed and do
you know what they all mean let's start
with the phrases on the seal of the
United States turn the bill to the back
and you'll notice that the American
Eagle and the pyramid both feature Latin
writing let's focus on the Eagle first
as we have a lot more things to explore
with the pyramid the letters can be
found right above the wings but the
meaning of them is often missed
translated as one out of many however
because of the way the words are placed
the sentence has even more possible
translations one is one for many men
another is one from many women and final
is one from many things however the
meaning of the sentence is still the
same it describes the action of many
things
uniting into one in this case bringing
together the 13 colonies and creating
the United States of America but that's
not the only Latin phrase you can find
we'll take a look at the phrases on the
pyramid and a few secret messages on
there later on but all Latin
inscriptions have to do with the history
of the United States letters on the
pyramid so let's look at the pyramid on
the Great Seal in more detail the final
design of the pyramid was accepted in
1782 the pyramid itself symbolizes
strength and duration of the United
States as a country but it holds many
more secrets you never noticed firstly
check out the Latin inscription you see
at the bottom it represents a newly
formed government and the beginning of
the new American era you might have
noticed the creepy eye at the top we'll
talk more about that later on but let's
pay more attention to the small symbols
you never noticed on the pyramid have
you ever noticed that the pyramid is
actually unfinished it comes with 13
steps which of course goes back to the
13 original US colonies we've already
mentioned earlier that the unfinished
pyramid comes with even more symbolism
and indicates future growth in the
nation and expansion do you see the
Roman numerals located on the bay
to the pyramid those stand for 1776
which was the date the founders chose to
represent the new American era of course
it's based on the bottom of the pyramid
and acts as a base for all future growth
we bet you had no idea a simple pyramid
can hold so much symbolism we're just
getting started just wait till we get to
the next quite controversial element
that's placed at the top of the pyramid
the all-seeing eye one of the most
talked-about symbols of the dollar bill
is definitely the all-seeing eye also
known as the Eye of Providence the eye
is of course controversial because of
its resemblance to the Illuminati sign
but stay tuned to hear more about that
and all other conspiracies in just a few
minutes the Aussie and I first appeared
as part of the standard iconography of
the Freemasons back in 1797 and went
through a couple of redrawing before
settling on the final version the symbol
has a direct connection to the
unfinished pyramid which represents
future growth and acts as a capstone the
direct meaning is of course religious as
the eye represents the all-seeing eye of
God keeping a watch on the country
however many have noticed that this
meaning could have changed as the symbol
of this triangle evolved through the
years the eye has also been noted in a
few versions of the Bible and was
adopted by masonry in 1797 the Latin
words above the eye were explained by
Charles Thompson the founding father who
was also chosen to complete the design
of the Great Seal the meaning of the eye
and the motto over it allude to the many
signal into positions of Providence in
favor of the American cause the effect
translation of the motto above the eye
means that the Providence favors our
undertakings
there's a hidden creature it's time to
take out a magnifying glass because
there's one thing we're positive you've
never noticed on the dollar bill unless
you studied it closely turn it to the
front of the bill and get closer to the
left edge of number one you see the arc
on the left side of the shield the right
side features leaves that there are no
leaves on the left side instead you can
find a small creature and many suspects
it's either an owl a spider or something
that holds a secret symbolic meaning
that's connected to the history of the
United States if you think about it the
symbol
and behind an owl would definitely add a
perfect touch to the bill that's already
full of secret elements a
similar-looking creature can also be
found at the bottom of the bill look
closely at the strange pattern between
the number one and the one dollar sign
do you see it the secret behind this
symbol is still unexplained and while
many think it's just a part of the
pattern others suspect it has a
secretive meaning the founding fathers
never shared with anyone else
conspiracy theorists also suspect the
owl is another symbol of Freemasons and
Illuminati but of course we'll probably
never know the truth do you think it's
an owl or just a pattern the eagle let's
pay attention to another American symbol
you probably know all too well bald
eagles represents strength beauty and
longevity and it first appeared as an
American symbol in 1782 but have you
noticed everything that's happening with
the eagle on the dollar bill the symbols
represent a lot more than just strength
and beauty Charles Thompson one of the
founding fathers described the American
Eagle as one of the most striking
symbols the eagle on the wing is rising
it flies freely and independently but
pay attention to what its holding in its
left Talon you can see the 13 arrows and
an olive branch and it's right the 13
arrows signify the war in 13 original
colonies and the olive branch signifies
peace there's also a reason why they're
placed on the left and right the right
side symbolizes dominance and the arrows
can be interpreted as a warlike gesture
the left talent shows a much more
peaceful offering as olive branches
symbolize peace and victory speaking of
the eagle did you know that the original
animal that represented the United
States was supposed to be a turkey the
idea was presented by Benjamin Franklin
who actually didn't particularly like
the idea of an eagle but that's a story
for another video let's get back to
exploring more hidden secrets in the
dollar bill the circled letters you've
probably noticed that the dollar bill
features some strange letters and by now
you know that every element on the bill
has a secret meaning if you turn the
bill to the front you'll notice a
circled letter on the left side of
George Washington's portrait these are
also known as the Federal Reserve seal
check your other bills and you might see
that these letters aren't all the same
although these might
have a secret meaning that talks about
the history of the United States they
can tell you exactly where every single
bill was printed pretty cool right as
you might know there are twelve
different US Federal Reserve Bank's
which are responsible for printing money
these letters go from a to I and they
represents twelve cities where you can
find the Federal Reserve Bank's you can
find these banks in Boston New York
Philadelphia Cleveland Richmond Atlanta
Chicago st. Louis Minneapolis Kansas
City Dallas and San Francisco so for
example you see the letter A it means
that your dollar bill was printed in
Boston or if you see the letter G it was
printed in Chicago the letter B stands
for New York and so on and so on if you
look closely at the letter you'll notice
the city's name in the actual circle
along with the state of the Federal
Reserve serial numbers speaking of
numbers let's have a closer look at the
serial numbers you can find on the bill
and they actually appear twice once
right below the Federal Reserve seal on
the left and right above the Treasury
seal on the right here's a little secret
on how you can easily spot if your bill
is actually fake check out the letter on
the Federal Reserve seal this letter
must match the first letter of the
serial number at all times if it doesn't
you're most likely dealing with
counterfeit cash then check out the
letter right under the serial number
that letter indicates how many times the
Bureau of Engraving and printing used
the same sequence of serial numbers they
usually print 832 bills per serial
number so if you see a letter A that
means this sequence was used for the
first time or if you see a letter V it
means it was used 22 times speaking of
the dollar bill rare serial numbers
could make your bill worth thousands of
dollars
so check if you see any of these digits
people are now buying dollar bills with
seven repeating digits of a serial
number in a row you might also check if
you have seven of a kind digits or four
digits in a row your dollar bill might
just be worth more than just a dollar
conspiracy theories if you look at these
symbols for a long time you'll start
seeing more and more strange things no
one can escape conspiracy theories not
even American money over the years
people started paying more and more
attention to the symbols on the dollar
bill and with that came various theories
and explanations of the story behind the
elements of course the all-seeing eye
points to the infamous Illuminati and
many believe that some of the Masons
were also members of Illuminati a secret
society that can control just about
every aspect of the world it's also been
pointed out that the 13 stars above the
Eagle connected to a hexagon which is
connected to satanic beliefs people also
claim that it's the same hexagon on the
pyramid and many think that the Roman
numerals represent the year when
Illuminati was first formed the tiny
mysterious owl that can be found on the
left side of number 1 was also connected
to the Freemasons and many people
believe it symbolizes Satanism we're
sure you can find more and more
triangles just about anywhere on the
dollar bill and many believe the money
holds even more hidden Illuminati
secrets what do you think are these
symbols more than just regular symbols
talking about the history of the United
States or is it all just one big
conspiracy theory we're not quite done
with conspiracy theories wait until you
see what you can do with the $20 bill
you can fold the $20 bill this is one of
the weirdest secrets we've shown you
today we've tried it and we're really
not sure what to think about this did
you know that you can fold a $20 bill in
a certain way that shows the New York
Twin Towers falling
it's a strange theory but we'll show you
how to do it so you can test it on your
own to make this work use an old $20
bill first fold the bill horizontally
then fold it into an L shape and fold it
the same way on the right side before we
move on check out the center of the bill
some claim if you look closely you can
see the Pentagon on fire then turn the
bill around in the center you will now
see the Twin Towers ablaze it's a
picture that can be easily compared to
the actual September 11th moment if you
do the same to the $5 bill you will see
the same images but the buildings are
still standing you can also see the Twin
Towers ablaze on a $10 bill while the
$50 bill only shows smoke the folding
Theory hasn't yet been confirmed as true
but you should definitely try folding it
and
for yourself of course you can also fold
the bill into a cool-looking origami
like this one that's it for the 10 most
mind-blowing secrets in the US dollar
for more videos like this one check out
10 secrets flight attendants don't want
you to know see you next time
[Music]